toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
funérailles au liban au lendemain de
violents affrontements qui ont fait sept
morts lors d'une manifestation à
beyrouth parmi les victimes six membres
du hezbollah et du mouvement amal qui
organisait ce rassemblement
ils exigeaient le départ du juge chargé
de l'enquêté sur l'explosion au port de
beyrouth l'année dernière on en parle
dès le début de ce journal
aux etats unis l'administration maiden
se tourner vers la cour suprême pour
contester une loi qui limite
l'avortement au texas une loi adoptée
par cet état du sud des états unis le
1er septembre dernier elle interdit
l'avortement au delà de six semaines
est ce
[Musique]
enfin nous parlerons de cette campagne
vaccinale entamée par le burundi jusque
là c'était l'un des seuls pays africains
a refusé la vaccination pour trouver le
comique 19 mai le pays va commencer à
vacciner sa population à grand renfort
de la chine pour uni a reçu hier cinq
cent mille 2
vaccins chinois sinofert
[Musique]
et
il est 20h bonsoir et bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez sur rt france
journée de deuil au liban après ces
violents affrontements qui ont eu lieu
hier à beyrouth et qui ont fait sept
morts et une trentaine de blessés six
des victimes étaient membres du
hezbollah mais aussi du mouvement amal
il s'agit des deux organisations fuite à
l'origine de la manifestation de jeudi
dirigé outre tarek litas il joue en
charge de l enquête sur l'explosion au
port de beyrouth explosion qui a fait
plus de 200 morts le 4 août 2020 un
rassemblement à l'écu lieu devant le
palais de justice de la capitale pour
exiger la démission de ce juge mais il a
mené à de graves affrontements les
victimes ont été abattus en pleine rue
le hezbollah accuse le parti chrétien
les forces libanaises des violences dont
qui font redouter une nouvelle guerre
civile dans le pays françois xavier
lambert et amaya soubelet
un pays en état de choc au lendemain
d'une fusillade meurtrière près du
palais de justice une journée sanglante
qui ravivent le spectre de la guerre
civile
la communauté internationale n'a pas
tardé à réagir la france appelle à un
apaisement des tensions tout comme
washington
ah oui john
soignons aux autorités libanaises dans
leurs appels au calme des appels à des
escalade des tensions ont été lancés la
santé et l'avenir de la démocratie
libanaise dépendent de la capacité de
ses citoyens a abordé les questions
difficiles en toute confiance et en
faisant confiance à l'état de droit
confiance dans l'état de droit dans leur
pays et par un dialogue pacifique avec
le nouveau gouvernement
la russie a de son côté appelé les
forces politiques à faire preuve de
retenue et de prudence pour résoudre les
problèmes ce jeudi des centaines de
partisans qui s'étaient réunis devant le
palais de justice pour exiger le
remplacement du juge chargé de l'enquêté
sur l'explosion du port de beyrouth
une journée qui a mené à des
affrontements
des échanges de tirs nourris entre des
hommes armés placé dans la manifestation
et des francs tireurs sur les toits des
immeubles
sous les tirs des habitants sont évacués
par les secouristes
derrière les véhicules blindés et les
chars qui bouclent l'accès au quartier
après plusieurs heures d'accrochages
l'armée libanaise a ramené la situation
au calme mais
ce qui s'est passé fera l'objet d'un
sûrs et sécuritaires et judiciaires et
je verrai pour ma part à ce que l'anc
est parviennent à la vérité sur ce qui
s'est passé afin de demander des comptes
aux responsables et aux instigateurs
comme tout autre enquête judiciaire y
compris l' enquête sur l'explosion du
port
qui était et restera une priorité de mon
travail et de mon engagement envers les
libanais et la communauté internationale
[Musique]
le juge tarek bitar est accusée par le
hezbollah et le mouvement amal de mener
une enquête partiale et ciblée
politiquement depuis plusieurs semaines
la pression est de plus en plus forte
sur le magistrat qui tente d'auditionner
d'anciens ministres chiites
parmi eux plusieurs ont saisi la justice
pour suspendre l'enquète notamment ali
hassan khalil et ghazi zeaiter dont les
plaintes ont été rejetées ce jeudi par
la cour de cassation l' enquête va donc
se poursuivre pour faire la lumière sur
les responsables de l'explosion qui a
tué 200 personnes le 4 août 2020 une
tragédie provoquée par le stockage sans
surveillance d'énormes quantités de
nitrate d'ammonium pointé du doigt pour
négligence criminelle les autorités
libanaises refuse toujours l'ouverture
d'une enquête internationale
et parmi les libanais c'est la crainte
qui demeure et elle n'est pas récente
c'est ce que nous explique mounir douma
ni des membres du parti ali manet
citoyens et citoyennes dans un état
écouter ce qui est très important c'est
qu'il y avait une énorme rectitude
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas nouvelle ce
qui s'est passé hier n'est qu'une des
manifestations de cette crise n'est pas
un événement isolé de ce par quoi passe
le pays il y à une destruction
systématique de la société qui est en
train qui est en train de prendre place
aujourd'hui il le restera encore une
fois dans ce dans ce pays que les
miséreux qui serviront de chair à canon
c'est la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes et encore une fois ce n'est pas
le résultat en fait tout tout ce qui se
passe dans la question de la question de
l' enquête la question de l'explosion on
va parler de l'intervention étrangère et
à tout ça ce ne sont que des excuses
pour faire en sorte de rappeler à la
situation qui à la population par donc
lui qui au kiki aux commandes et faire
en sorte que les gens acceptent la
situation terrible dans laquelle ils
sont
en afghanistan un attentat suicide fait
au moins 41 morts dans une mosquée
chiite située à kandahar dans le sud du
pays elle a eu lieu au moment de la
grande prière du vendredi l'un de deux
kamikazes
exposés à l'intérieur de la mosquée et
l'autre à l'entrée une attaque qui
arrive exactement une semaine après
l'attentât perpétré contre une mosquée
chiite toujours mais de koundouz ils
avaient été revendiqués par
l'organisation terroriste l'état
islamique écoutez quelques témoins de
cette explosion cet attentat qui a eu
lieu aujourd'hui
c'était l'heure de la prière du vendredi
un des kamikazes est venu s'est tenue
près de la porte un autre était déjà
dans la mosquée à ce moment là celui qui
était dehors a essayé d'entrer mais les
gardes ont tiré dessus et les kamikazes
se sont fait exploser dans la mosquée
il y avait je crois à trois kamikazes
les trois sont allés à la mosquée
l'un d'eux n'a pas pu entrer et s'est
fait sauter devant la mosquée tandis que
les deux autres sont entrés et ils se
sont fait exploser deux dans
la revente rue avait une arme à feu et
quand il s'est fait arrêter il a tiré
permettant à ses complices d'entrer dans
la mosquée et de se faire exploser
il y avait des blessés des morts sur le
sol de la mosquée ils ont été emmenés à
l'hôpital
nous demandons à tout le monde de prier
pour nos morts et nos blessés
autre titre de ce journal
l'administration de la maison blanche
qui annonce ce vendredi qu'elle va faire
appel à la cour suprême pour bloquer une
loi contre l'avortement au texas un
nouveau rebondissement dans une bataille
juridique qui dure depuis déjà plusieurs
semaines pour en parler on retrouve
notre correspondant à washington
thomas bonnin
thomas bonsoir c'est donc un nouveau
chapitre dans cette opposition entre les
autorités fédérales et les autorités
texanes autour de cette loi qui limite
donc l'avortement dans cet état du sud
des états unis
absolument on a appris il ya quelques
instants donc le gouvernement de joe
biden allait déposer un nouveau recours
devant la cour suprême pour tenter de
bloquer cette loi contre l'avortement au
texas alors il faut rappeler que cette
loi interdit le recours à l'ivg et g à
partir du moment où une activité
cardiaque a été détecté chez l'embryon
ce qui correspond environ à six semaines
de grossesse il n'y a pas d'exception ni
pour les cas d'inceste ni pour les cas
de viol c'est une loi qui avait été
signé au mois de mai dernier par le
gouverneur républicain de l'état du
texas et en septembre déjà la cour
suprême s'était penché sur la
constitutionnalité de cette mesure mais
elle ne l'avait pas bloquée à l'époque
parce que cette loi est un peu inédite
parce que c'est aux citoyens que revient
à la charge de la faire respecter
avec un système de dénonciation et de
récompenses alors depuis on assiste à
une bataille juridique entre les
autorités fédérales et les autorités de
l'état du texas il ya d'abord eu une
plainte de la part du gouvernement
américain pour faire bloquer cette loi
du texas cela a été le cas donc pendant
quelques temps et puis il ya eu un appel
qui a été lancé qui a été fait par la
justice de l'état du texas et que cet
appel à rejeter donc la plainte du
gouvernement ce qui veut dire qu'à
l'heure actuelle cette loi limitant
l'accès à l'avortement est en vigueur
dans l'état du texas on va donc
maintenant avoir une deuxième décision
de la cour suprême d'ici ces prochaines
semaines on sait que les juges de cette
cour suprême sont à majorité
conservateurs et la question maintenant
c'est de savoir s'ils vont remettre en
cause la loi de 1973 sur l'avortement
qui fait foi aujourd'hui aux états unis
il s'agit aussi d'une bataille politique
pour joe biden qui fait face dans ce
dossier à des élus républicains en
premier lieu desquels il ya donc ce
gouverneur républicain de l'état du
texas greg abbott qui s'opposent à joe
biden sur énormément de sujets en ce
moment que ce soit sur le volet
sanitaire ou donc pour cette loi contre
l'avortement et puis il faut noter pour
finir que d'autres états vont suivre
avec attention la décision qui va être
rendu par la cour suprême des etats-unis
parce que d'autres états gouvernés par
des conservateurs pourraient eux aussi
être tentée de mettre en place de
nouvelles mesures plus restrictives pour
le recours à l'ivg merci beaucoup pour
tout ces précisions thomas buanec en
direct de washington merci à vous
situation sanitaire toujours aussi
inquiétantes en russie le pays connaît
tant nouveau record de décès liés aux
cours aux navires us à moscou épicentre
de cette contamination qu'on retrouve
notre correspondante des ragots fans
999 des scellés au kobus 19 dénombre
aujourd'hui la russie il s'agit d'un
record absolu depuis le début de la
pandémie les contaminations est en
hausse plus de 32000 cas ces dernières
24 heures les autorités n'envisage
pourtant pas de confinement général et
c'est de rassurer le monde des affaires
la situation est difficile surtout dans
certaines régions mais il n'y a aucune
raison d'introduire un confinement au
niveau fédéral je voudrais rassurer nos
entreprises
le monde des affaires les gens faire
cela serait inopportun car le
confinement nationale aurait un impact
négatif sur les gens et surtout le pays
il n'y a aucune raison à cela
la situation à moscou épicentre de
l'épidémie a aussi devient de plus en
plus compliqué plus de 6600 nouveau
cadre de corona virus ont été recensés à
une journée avec presque 1500
hospitalisation le maire de moscou
sergueï semaine ils envisagent certaines
restrictions pour contrer l'épidémie
mais ne précise pas lesquels pour le
moment hirter
mais ne brasse pas mal
en général ils ne seront pas de
développer la ville malgré la pandémie
moscou vivra sa vie plein marasme au
développement se poursuivra oui
certaines restrictions sont possibles
oui certaines mesures et c'est le type
de court terme sont possibles mais la
ville en général s'est déjà adapté à la
pente mais gagner et nous comprenons que
rien ne nous arrêtera
c'est essentiel pour le bien être des
gens pour les revenus des citoyens
le développement d un fossé développe
daruda
gratuite et bismarck
plus de 51 millions de russes ont reçu
au moins une dose de vaccin ce qui reste
peu élevé pour une population de 146
millions le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov à lui qualifié
d'irresponsable la décision de ne pas se
faire vacciner dans un tel contexte
épidémique
situation sanitaire en france où il
faudra désormais payer pour se faire
dépister contre le colis 19 août et 44
euros pour les tests pcr et entre une
vingtaine d'euros et 30 euros pour les
antigénique quelques exceptions
toutefois pour les mineurs les quatre
contacts mais aussi les personnes qui
ont reçu une prescription médicale
double objectif du gouvernement faire
des économies la prise en charge à 100 %
de ces tests diagnostiques a coûté
environ 2,6 milliards d'euros à
l'assurance maladie en 2020 il s'agit
aussi d'inciter les français à se faire
vacciner écouter quelques réactions
parce qu'on veut pas se faire vacciner
en obligés de payer c'est dommage mais
bon si on peut le faire je respecte ses
choix je continuerai à prier c'est un
choix qu'on a fait ne pas vacciner donc
p g serré stupeur embêtant mais bon
on aurait préféré plus gratuite ça dure
plus longtemps je pense que mon avis il
y aura certainement des soucis pour plus
tard ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens contre
ddt afin de se couvrir
des défauts des fautes est pour les gens
qui sont pas vaccinés c'est une
obligation déguisée de la vaccination
voilà maintenant où est la liberté des
personnes
le burundi entame sa campagne de
vaccination le pays a reçu hier ses
premiers vaccins grâce à un don de la
chine 500 mille doses de sinopharm
longtemps dans le déni face à la
pandémie le pays change de cap dans son
combat contre la pandémie avec une
vaccination qui sera basé sur le
volontariat la classe d'ailleurs un
virage à 180° c est ce qu opère le
gouvernement burundais en acceptant de
recevoir des vaccins contre le commis 19
les précieuses d'eau sont arrivés hier à
bujumbura un don de 500 mille doses du
vaccin sinopharm la chine apprécié
hautement les mesures prises par le
gouvernement pour monde est
contre le coc beef 19 et suivra c'était
fort pour accompagner les familles
commentait dans cette lutte ces vaccins
sont homologués par l'eau naissent aussi
et comme excellence madame
l'ambassadrice l'a signalé aussi
l'aube accès ne vient pas remplacer les
mesures d'hygiène masi le palier c'est
très important des mesures d'hygiène
indispensables à la mi-juillet les pays
a été submergé par la vague delta
longtemps dans le déni sous la
présidence de pierre nkurunziza son
successeur evariste ndayishimiye avait
qualifié le kobe 19 de plus grand ennemi
des burundais partageant d'ordinaire peu
ces données le pays avait alors
communiquer ces derniers chiffres plus
de 19000 330 cas et 14 décès après
plusieurs mois d'une politique
gouvernementale de l'autruche la
population est divisée quant à
l'efficacité du vaccin
je pense qu'il n'y a personne qui
refusera de prendre ce vaccin car c'est
très important parce que beaucoup de
gens sont infectés par le cos vie de 19
alors si on reçoit ce vaccin il n'y aura
pas de mort à cause du coc vie 19 moi
personnellement je me sens prêt à
prendre ce vaccin
je ne me vois pas accepter ce vaccin ou
accepter d'être vaccinés
parce que j'ai entendu que même si on
est vaccinés on peut toujours avoir le
virus est aussi affecté les autres
si certains s'inquiètent des effets du
vaccin d'autres dénoncent le manque
d'intérêt accordé de façon générale aux
populations africaines sur les questions
sanitaires je ne pense pas que on
devrait avoir cet engouement pour nos
colonnes le boxer antico vide lorsqu'on
n'a pas manifesté cela avec ebola ou
avec d'autres
d'autres calamités jeudi des sanitaires
selon continent du côté du gouvernement
on garde le nouveau cap un pass and i
ter sera instaurée le 1er novembre et
tout habitant qui désirent sortir de la
capitale économique bujumbura devra
présenter un test qu'ovide négatif un
autre lot de 124 mille doses de johnson
and johnson de l'initiative africaine
havas est également attendue d'ici la
fin du mois d'octobre
direction la tunisie ou calle sayyed a
présidé hier le premier conseil des
ministres en vertu des mesures
exceptionnelles qui ont été décrété le
22 septembre dernier l'occasion pour le
locataire du palais de carthage de
réaffirmer son statut d'homme fort du
pays en rejetant toute ingérence
étrangère le point avec notre
correspondant à tunis bassam celle ici
la tunisie est un état libre et
indépendant il est hors de question de
s'ingérer dans ses affaires c'est par
ces mots prononcés sur un ton ferme que
le président tunisien kaïs sayyed a
ouvert hier le premier conseil des
ministres palais de carthage en présence
de najlae bouden et de sa nouvelle
équipe un message adressé à ceux qui
l'accusent de déstabiliser le processus
de transition qu'il a amorcé le 25
juillet dernier
dans son viseur l'ancien président
tunisien moncef marzouki qui s'était
félicité mardi chez nos confrères de
france 24 de la proposition du conseil
permanent de la francophonie de reporter
d'un an le 18e sommet de la francophonie
qui était initialement prévue les 20 et
21 novembre prochain sur l'île de djerba
moncef marzouki qui n'a jamais caché son
opposition au président sayyed avait
appelé la france à ne pas soutenir le
coup d'état en tunisie c'est suite à ses
propos que l'homme fort de la tunisie a
demandé l'ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire
soulignant la souveraineté appartient au
peuple tout en annonçant le retrait du
passeport diplomatique de l'ancien
président qu'il a décrit comme celui qui
parcourt les capitales étrangères dans
le but de nuire aux intérêts de la
tunisie autre sujet sur la table de ce
premier conseil des ministres les états
unis le locataire du palais de carthage
s'est interrogé sur le fait que la
situation tunisienne soit au coeur des
travaux de la commission des affaires
étrangères du congrès américain
nous entretenons des relations de
coopération
mais dans le respect de la souveraineté
et de la volonté du peuple les relations
entre les deux pays resteront solides
même si un certain nombre de tunisiens
qui sont écoutés à l'étranger tente de
discréditer ce qui se passe en tunisie
peu de temps après le conseil des
ministres le président de la république
a reçu dans les salons de la présidence
l'ambassadeur des états unis en tunisie
donald blom pour lui faire part de son
mécontentement il lui rappeler qu'il
n'accepterait aucune ingérence dans les
affaires de son pays c'est dans un
communiqué rendu public hier sur la page
officielle
la présidence de la république a indiqué
que cette rencontre a pu clarifier
quelques sujets tout en rappelant les
liens forts et solides qui lient les
deux pays
politique en allemagne où les principaux
partis s'entendent pour former un
cabinet a pris dix jours de négociations
un accord préliminaire a été trouvé
entre les sociaux démocrates les verts
et libero il s'agit de former un
gouvernement tripartite qui devrait être
dirigée par olaf scholz les parties
doivent maintenant s'entendre sur un
programme commun notamment sur la
limitation de l'endettement et ou encore
le fait de ne pas augmenter les impôts
si les tractactions tractations
aboutissent la coalition devrait prendre
les commandes du pays de
retour en france où ce vendredi un
hommage était rendu à samuel pâti à la
veille de la date anniversaire de
l'assassinât de l'enseignant tué pour
avoir montré des caricatures du prophète
musulman mahomet en classe tous les
établissements scolaires de france
étaient donc invités à se recueillir
sous différentes formes aujourd'hui une
minute de silence discussions autour de
la laïcité écoles collèges et lycées on
avait la liberté d'organiser cette
journée d'hommage en visite dans un
lycée parisien le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a lui évoqué les moyens pour
s'opposer aux actes de terrorisme comme
celui dont il a été victime saigne pas
de si ce
que nous avons proposé à ça c'est
justement la sérénité et la force de la
république et de la démocratie sont des
valeurs simples mais des valeurs très
importantes et je suis toujours
rassérénés de voir que les élèves
spontanément parle de la liberté et
savent que la liberté est un bien
extraordinairement précieux qu'elle doit
être défendue tout simplement la laïcité
on doit toujours le rappeler aussi elle
est garante des libertés sur bien des
aspects un des élèves interrogés tout à
l'heure sur la liberté de culte par
exemple c'est justement ce que la
laïcité permet la laïcité n'est pas un
athéisme d'état la laïcité permet à
chacun le croire ou de ne pas croire et
de croire dans la religion qui est la
sienne et qui d'ailleurs peut évoluer
dans une vie c'est très important de le
dire parce que certains essayent de
dépeindre la laïcité comme quelque chose
qui aurait à l'encontre des religions je
dirais que c'est tout le contraire
la laïcité permet la liberté donc la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
c'est justement ça qui est beau et qui
est précieux
alexandre langlois ancien policier et
candidat à la présidentielle à tête le
csa en justice ils réclament une
révision du calcul du temps de parole
des candidats exclus des sondages et des
médias le prétendant à l'elysée se sent
lésé il est justement avec nous pour en
parler
on soir alexandre langlois et merci
d'être en direct avec nous en juin
dernier vous vous êtes donc déclarer
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22 aujourd'hui vous venez de
déposer donc avec vos avocats un recours
en référé au tribunal administratif de
paris donc à l'encontre du scs arts vous
dénoncez le mode de calcul du temps de
parole des candidats qui provoquerait
selon vous des inégalités entre les
aspirants à l'elysée ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer le sens de votre démarche
bonsoir oui effectivement le temps de
parole des candidats est calculé par
rapport à plusieurs choses les résultats
aux dernières élections et également à
leurs résultats dans les sondages mais
du coup les sondages y aurait aucune
règle qui permet de savoir comment les
sondages sont faits et qui encadrent ces
deux qui peut est rentré dans les
sondages donc la demande qu'elle fait au
csa c'est de clarifier ses règles parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons quand même à
quelque chose d'assez ironique et
amusant les sondages donnent gagnant de
ce pas m au second tour de la
présidentielle
deux personnes qui ne sont pas encore
officiellement candidat donc en fait
qu'à une orientation médiatique des par
les sondages et pour contrer sa demande
d rect toute simple parce que conseil
constitutionnel avait dit que il était
garant du pluralisme
du pluralisme et que le pluralisme était
une garantie de la démocratie et que
justement ça débouche sur la sincérité
du scrutin si les gens n'ont pas toutes
les informations pour pouvoir aller
voter pour pouvoir trouver les
parrainages ça fausse le scrutin
également comme il ya un vide juridique
on a également saisi le premier ministre
pour lui demander en urgence de
clarifier les règles est justement de
décrire des règles sur ce sujet là soit
par décret soit par une loi en urgence
pour que justement ce vide juridique qui
profite à des personnes qui sont auto
désignés se termine par quelque chose de
légal j'ai finalement les ce qu'on
retrouve dans les uns dans l'est dans
les sondages ce sont les personnes que
l'on voit les plus le plus sur le
plateau sur les plateaux de télévision
est ce que vous vous estimez que ça ça
biaise le débat savièse le jeu de cette
élection présidentielle a effectivement
pour expliquer quelque chose pour gagner
des électeurs pour gagner des soutiens
si les gens ne vous connaissent pas vous
ne pouvez effectivement pas propagé vos
idées et donc effectivement ça ne
participe pas au débat démocratique on a
un exemple je suis passé dans une
émission sur ces 8 ben le lendemain j'ai
eu des coups de téléphone de plusieurs
personnes qui disaient on savait pas que
vous étiez candidat ça nous intéresse on
veut vous soutenir donc il ya vraiment
un rôle de cause à effet est pas le
poids dans le système médiatique en tous
les cas pour nous on s'enferme sur des
sondages qui peut faire plaisir qu'il
peut faire les choses mais il ya déjà
plus de 36 candidats déclarés ce qui est
déjà deux fois moins qu'en 2017 mais
donc ça permettrait aussi d'avoir le
sonder les gens réellement là on a
l'impression qu'en fait il ya un filtre
médiatique on ne compte dans les
commandes de sondages qui disent voilà
ce qu'on va proposer aux français et
vous n'aurez le choix que que nous ce
qu'on en a sur ce qu'on a décidé dans la
démocratie ce n'est pas ça la démocratie
c'est les électeurs qui doivent dessiner
doit pas y avoir de filtre entre eux et
les candidats
vous êtes officiellement candidat ce
n'est pas le cas d'eric zemmour et vous
lisez tout à l'heure finalement est-ce
que ce n'est pas injuste qu'ils soient
omniprésents sur dans les médias alors
que vous vous y trouve beaucoup plus
rarement
pas juste c'est pas cette question là
pour le moment il n'ya pas d'empêchement
légale à cette décision va ya un
paradoxe est que le sait ça avait voulu
que d'y limiter son temps de parole qui
a dû le faire démissionner de son poste
a priori sans raison parce qu'il n'était
pas candidat et mettant le voit autant
que jamais dans toutes les couvertures
de médias il est encore plus omniprésent
dans les médias donc pour le moment
légalement rien ne s'y oppose après ça
ne semble pas légitime c'est pour ça
qu'on demande que la légitimité soit
cadré par quelque chose de légal et
c'est ça ou visuel ce flou juridique est
aujourd'hui par exemple monsieur zemmour
continuer de pouvoir mais
sans pour autant être candidat ce qui
pose quand même difficulté est ce que
vous estimez être boycottée par les
médias vous êtes souvent invitée sur des
plateaux télé
ça dépend des moments on a eu la chance
qu'on a lancé la campagne d'avoir
quelques petites couvertures médiatiques
de quelques journaux de rt france qui
étaient présents après le boycott c'est
des fois aussi la méconnaissance parce
que les médias aussi sur certains se
disent qu'est ce qui va être vendeur
qu'est ce qui ne va pas être vendeur et
badiou c'est de savoir comment on peut
faire des choses je sais que du temps où
j'étais syndicaliste aussi encore
d'ailleurs est encore policiers mais on
est et on a été boycottée par les médias
sur demande a priori gouvernementale
certains journalistes ne nous l'ont dit
en disant qu'à écouter voilà comme vous
dérange et robin les médias on a eu un
choix soit de plus vous invitez soit
plus avoir les informations officielles
ce qui pose une question c'est j'en veux
pas aux médias pour le coup là j'en veux
à des consignes politiques pour limiter
la parole est dans une démocratie on
devrait pas limiter la parole encore moi
en ce jour d'hommage à samuel petit
merci beaucoup pour tout ces précisions
sur ce recours que vous avez donc déposé
alexandre langlois merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions merci à vous voilà pour
cette édition merci à vous d'avoir suivi
prochain au journal dans une trentaine
de minutes à tout à l'heure
et
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on dit dans
les grandes entreprises multinationales
de saint gobain russie ukraine on a
beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel qu'il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la